devastador y mortal en california
comunidades enteras fueron incineradas y
la calidad del aire en el estado es la
peor del planeta científicos del
gobierno federal concluyeron hace dos
años que las emisiones de carbono
podrían triplicar el número de incendios
forestales en el oeste pero el domingo
en nevada el presidente de trump dejó de
lado la ciencia por favor recuerda las
palabras muy simple gestión de bosques
por favor recuerde se trata de la
gestión de los bosques y otras cosas
pero la gestión de los bosques
trump hizo esta afirmación hace dos años
después de reunirse con el presidente de
finlandia diciendo que el país prevenir
los incendios rastreando sus bosques en
un mitin en el mes pasado culpó a
california por no limpiar sus pisos de
hojas
estoy un poco agotado de que tengamos
que seguir debatiendo este tema
esta es una emergencia climática
el debate se ha terminado en torno al
cambio climático solo vean al estado de
california no es un debate intelectual
ni siquiera que sea discutible o el
candidato demócrata a la presidencia joe
biden dijo en twitter durante el fin de
semana la ciencia es clara y las señales
mortales como los incendios en el oeste
son inconfundibles el cambio climático
plantea una amenaza existencial a
nuestra forma de vida
mientras el presidente de trump lucha
por un segundo mandato está doblando su
agenda anti climática para apelar a sus
principales partidarios
[Aplausos]